looking at matt whistler and what he's
done
out of the bullpen this year been very
very good
he's going to be the opener and we'll
see how how far he can go it's going to
be a bullpen game today for the twins
the perez is it first two down and now
jorge solaire
checked his swing but he went
and whistler has a scoreless hitless
first inning
head on booby's looking pretty good
though he's learning era's not going to
be up there very long
you know he's got really good commands
especially fastball change up
combination and he will work in a
breaking ball belmont goes in first
nobody out for
mitch garver
off speed and mondassy picks it off
well that wasn't your tailor-made double
play ground ball but the royals turned
it anyway this first inning continues
now for eddie rosario
and now fastball's hit up the middle and
mondassey is there catching the line
drive and bubic has a scoreless first
inning
the base is empty for nikki lopez
and that is into left field for a base
hit and the royals first hit tonight
salvi was
hit by a pitch in the first inning
on the ground left side
and adrianza throws across the diamond
and that's all for the royals in the
third so bubitch has set down the last
six the only hit he's given up
was to jorge polanco
toward the hole
odyssey's got a good arm but the throw
pulls mcgroom off the bag and polanco
has both twins hits the twins have a
runner at first base with two out and
mitch garber coming up
who didn't need it kind of looking at a
fastball second strikeout for boobage we
get to the fourth inning of play it's
the royals nothing and the twins dump it
struck out
his first time up
and he still strikes out on an off speed
pitch
one down count of one and two to hunter
dozier
and he went around there and it's strike
three back-to-back strikeouts for devon
now the batter is going to be ryan
mcbroom two and two to mcbroom and
another strikeout smeltzer has struck
out the side
as the royals go down one two three in
the fourth inning
cruz walked his first time up
there's a ball hit to left deep to left
and that ball is gone
off the facing of the second deck
crews hitting his seventh of the year
and the twins take the first lead
you can see what they were trying to do
perez behind the plate wanted high
fastball watch where this one is he
wants it high
it's middle just inside the middle
nelson was dialed in on that speed three
walks
to this inning and now it's going to
keep the enemy alive and here's where
buxton he won't be patient he'll look
for something early and jump on it
that's to left there's his first hit of
the series dropping one softly into left
field gonzalez around third he'll score
and the twins take a two-to-nothing lead
so with merrifield now the runner at
first gordon and two down here in the
top of the fifth inning
deep to the left field corner
and
off the wall rosario firing the second
base they got to play he's out
rosario with a perfect strike from the
left field corner
and the inning ends with an outfield
assist
and now it's going to be eddie rosario
the middle on the base head rosario's
aboard
and
hold up at second base
marwin gonzalez he lined out hard to
third his first time he's also walked
and scored
[Applause]
call third strike
they'll take it every strike is called
that's a foot outside that was a ball
runner at second base two out dozier
right now mcbroom on deck
roller to short
clifford pitches a scoreless sixth
finish
driven hard to the gap in right center
hard off the wall and that might be the
most encouraging thing twins fans have
seen from cenote to date kepler oh for
one with a walk
how about getting them in they got him
overhead
deep in the corner ceno will wheel
around third and it's kepler with an rbi
single
and a three-nothing lead
crews started the scoring hitting a
rocket
the facing of the second deck and left
field a lead-off home run in the fourth
a blast left center field headed to the
bullpen he's done it again
i just i don't know what to say his
fifth home run against kansas city
pitching in seven games and it's a four
nothing twins lead
top of the ninth inning twins four
royals nothing let's see if zach mattel
can close things up here tonight
that's driven to center field and deep
buxton is back and that is gone and
hunter dozier is homered in back-to-back
games it is 4-1 in the ninth inning so
bloop single to right center by franco
and here comes gordon waits 3-1 and the
pitch line to right vargas the catch
throws back to first base double play
and the ball game is over and the twins
win the game 4-1 and the twins end up
taking this series three games to one